ما كنت تتحدث عنه
[موسيقى]
كنت اتحدث ان الاشتباكات مستمره وان
الطيران الان يحلق في سماء الخرطوم خاصه
قبل ساعات كانت الاشتباكات عنيفه واستخدمت
فيها
استخدم فيها الطيران وكذلك الاسلحه
الثقيله نسمع جرابات ومواقع متفرقه جنوب
الخرطوم وفي شركه نيل هي شرق الخرطوم هذه
الاشتباكات كذلك في بالقرب من المدينه
الرياضيه التي كانت قد انطلقت منها هذه
المظاهرات
ينطلقت من هذه الاشتباكات في بشكل عنيف في
هذه المنطقه
هنالك نداء من الاطباء ايضا مجددوا النداء
لفتح المسارات
لمحاوله لانقاذ الجراحه تحولنا الاتصال
باقرب مستشفى لنا في هذه المنطقه يقول ان
قسم الطوالي في هذا المستشفى متوقف تماما
خوفا من هذه الاشتباكات وكذلك صعوبه
الوصول اليه سواء كانت السيارات الاسعاف
او غيرها هنالك نداء ايضا من وزاره الصحه
الاتحاديه لفتح المسارات او وسط الخرطوم
ويتحدثون عن جرحى ويتحدثون عن ظروف
انسانيه بالغه التعقيل في هذه المنطقه
هنالك مخاوف من اشتداد هذا القذف من
الاسلحه الثقيله هنا في الاحياء في
الاحياء تخوفون من سقوط قذايف على الاحياء
المهوله بالسكان تعلم ان الخرطوم بها
حوالي اكثر او نحو 8 مليون النسمه بدات
الان الظروف الانسانيه تتساقم بسبب انقطاع
التيار الكهربائي وانقطاع المياه عن معظم
هذه الولايه هيئه الكهرباء تقول تجد صعوبه
في التحرك لاصلاح هذه الاعطال وكذلك هيئه
توفير المياه هيئه مياه ولايه الخرطوم
تقول انها لا تستطيع ان ترسل فرق
لاصلاح هذه الاعطال بسبب
الظروف وبسبب هذه الاشتباكات على كلنا
النداءات ايضا تتصاعد من المنظمات المجتمع
المدني من الامم المتحده من الاحزاب
السياسيه والقوى السياسيه جميعها الان
يبعثون
مناشدات قويه الى الرئيس مجلس يدوي الى
نائب رئيس مجلس
السيادهن يستطيع فيها المواطن ان يرتب
اوضاعه خاصه في شهر رمضان هنالك احتياجات
ماستر السوق الان اصيب بشلل كامل توقفت
ايضا المخابز الا القليل في بعضها البعيد
من داخل الاحياء هنالك صعوبات الان في
الحصول على هذه الضروريات يحاول
داخل الحي مثلا التحرك في مساحات قليله
جدا اذا وجدوا
اييي اماكن مخابز مفتوحه او اي شيء يمكن
ان يتناولوا فيه اغراضهم الغذائيه هنالك
الانظار ايضا تتجه الى
الوساطات الدوليه والاتحاد الافريقي الان
انا اتحدث واسمع صوت
الطيران يحلق فوق سماء الخرطوم متوقع ايضا
وصول
الرئيس او مفوض الاتحاد الافريقي اليوم
الى الخرطوم
[موسيقى]